los pedidos llegan rápido al restaurante
de Aurelio ferrasa para mantenerlo en
funcionamiento este empresario cuenta
con un equipo de unos 15 empleados
no solamente hay trabajadores italianos
la razón falta mano de obra local por
esto Aurelio acude a trabajadores
extranjeros
hay una ausencia de personal italiano
generalizada no se encuentran empleados
para servir en el comedor trabajar en la
cocina o en el campo así que me vi
obligado a buscar mano de obra
extranjera que nos apoyará
de 28 años proviene de bogadicio en
sumalia cruzó el Mediterráneo en 2016
[Música]
desde el año pasado ayuda en la cocina
me interesa aprender los oficios del
restaurante
he aprendido mucho Aquí quiero seguir
formándome y aprender a cocinar un día
Espero llegar a ser un chef profesional
Aurelio también cuenta con 130 hectáreas
de tierra de su propiedad parte de la
cual está confiada a una cooperativa
compuesta por migrantes
este año para reclutar trabajadores
agrícolas Aurelio aprovechará un decreto
del gobierno italiano expedirá casi 83
mil visados de trabajo en los próximos
meses casi 13.000 más que en 2022
una buena oportunidad este decreto es
una buena oportunidad porque nos permite
Buscar en otros lugares el personal que
no podemos encontrar aquí en Italia
personal ya no puede ser en la propia
zona de la empresa tenemos que
expandirnos a otros países a países esta
mañana en las oficinas del principal
sindicato agrícola italiano Aurelio ha
acudido a ser oficial superior
para solicitar un permiso de residencia
para un trabajador que se encuentra en
el extranjero cada empresario debe
presentar un contrato de trabajo y
pruebas de la solidez financiera de la
actividad si resulta que el trabajador
no cumple las condiciones para
permanecer en Italia el empresario Se
compromete a pagar los gastos de
devolución del trabajador a su país
se trata de trabajadores de una
treintena de países entre ellos Argelia
túnez y senegal como la de Aurelio se
han presentado cerca de 280.000
solicitudes una prueba de la necesidad
generalizada mano de obra en Italia en
su siguiente no es suficiente
necesitamos más manos mucho más que los
cupos que se han abierto
al menos 100.000 trabajadores además de
los que acaba de indicar el decreto
el Ministerio del interior italiano
estudia aumentar aún más estas cuotas es
una forma de que el gobierno anime a los
inmigrantes a entrar en el país por vías
legales uno de los pilares de la
política migratoria de la actual
ejecutivo italiano que al mismo tiempo
quiere desincentivar la inmigración
ilegal a través del Mediterráneo tenemos
que controlar las salidas por el
Mediterráneo Europa es fundamental debe
ayudarnos a proteger las fronteras
europeas porque más cruces significan
más muertes en el mar desde enero 35.000
migrantes han desembarcado en Italia
tras abandonar África por mar esta cifra
es cuatro veces superior a la del mismo
periodo del año pasado ante esta
afluencia el gobierno ha declarado el
estado de emergencia migratoria durante
seis meses se destina millones de euros
a liberar plazas de acogida y
descongestionar centros saturados como
este de la isla de lampedusa estas
personas que llegan entran en el sistema
de acogida o salen esto se decide en
función de su expediente
dependiendo de sus antecedentes cada
inmigrante recibirá un permiso de
residencia o una notificación de
expulsión del territorio italiano
esa mañana en Roma una treintena de
asociaciones se manifestaban a pocos
pasos del parlamento quieren Enviar un
mensaje a los senadores que debaten el
endurecimiento de las condiciones para
la concesión de visados humanitarios
si aumentan los inmigrantes sin
documentos también lo hará el trabajo
irregular la explotación elevación
fiscal puede que quieran devolverlos a
todos pero lo cierto Es que no se Irán
se quedarán aquí a nuestro país le
interesa que estas personas tengan
permiso de residencia y paguen impuestos
mamá de un procede de Costa de Marfil
cruzó el Mediterráneo en 2008
hoy deplora el enfoque policial del
gobierno italiano que prevé aumentar el
número de centros de repatriación la
expulsión no es la solución la solución
es permitir que estas personas que
llevan diez o quince años viviendo en
este territorio tengan un proceso de
integración
Esto es lo más importante porque las
expulsiones cuestan más al gobierno e
Italia nunca ha conseguido hacer
expulsiones
en 2022 el país expulsó a 8.000 personas
según las estimaciones hay casi 500.000
inmigrantes indocumentados en suelo
italiano
[Música]